bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau et binaire et
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder la
problématique des données pondérées
notamment des pondérations de kate et
leur prise en compte notamment lorsqu'on
un plan d'échantillonnage complexe et
pour ça on aura au cours pas kitsch
serait donc bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle session est donc aujourd'hui on
va faire un petit point comme sur les
différents types de pont
d'échantillonnage ans pour bien
comprendre la différence entre un
échantillonnage aléatoire un
échantillonnage en strates et un ancien
d'échantillonnage en grappes et comment
du coup on va pouvoir prendre ça en
compte correctement dans nos enquêtes
puisque très souvent lorsqu'on travaille
sur des grandes enquêtes
ces dernières ont fait l'objet de plans
d échantillonnage un peu complexes et
souvent on dispose une variable de
pondération or il importe de prendre en
compte correctement cette variable de
pondération dans nos données on va
agrandir
voilà l'écran vous avez vous il y est
habitué comme d'habitude l'interface de
la studio je vais tout de suite créé un
nouveau projet pour la session
d'aujourd'hui
new directory ou project donc c'est le
webinaire aujourd'hui le numéro 10
et nous allons être prêts pour démarrer
alors tout d'abord on va peut-être faire
un tout petit récapitulatif sur les
différents types d' enquête puisque on a
souvent des variables de pondération
mais l'erreur à ces fréquences et
souvent se contente de prendre de tenir
compte que de la variable de pondération
sont forcément comme en compte le plan
d'échantillonnage complexe
ce qu'il faut retenir des va c'est que
nous variable de pondération elle peut
venir de différentes situations
alors je vous propose d'aller rapidement
sur le site des webinaires et d'aller
sur la page de la séance d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je vous ai rajouté quelques liens vers
des présentations en français les
différents type d'échantillon d'âge
alors pour rappel ça c'est juste pour
que vous puissiez visualiser les choses
le principe général des conquêtes c'est
qu'on va tirer au sort des individus
dans une population
et comme ce type d'individus sont
sélectionnés de manière aléatoire
on va pouvoir du coup on appliquer sa
poule de statistiques justement c'est
parce qu'un caractère aléatoire que on
va pouvoir calculer des intervalles de
confiance ont fermé tests de comparaison
je vous avez ici une illustration un
supposons que nous ayons une population
totale qui nous intéresse je vais tirer
au sort des individus
je vais parmi les individus ans qui
était mesuré une certaine grandeur
par exemple je vais mesurer leur taille
une taille moyenne qui serait je ne sais
pas d'un mètre 65 dans mon échantillon
je sais que la taille moyenne de la
population n'est pas forcément
exactement 1 m 65 puisque mon
échantillon est pas exactement identique
à la population mais comme le tirage au
sort a été fait là toi on peut donc
considérer que notre échantillon et dits
représentatifs et sachant que je tirais
au sort là quatre individus sur 25 je
vais pouvoir calculer un intervalle de
confiance autour de ma valeur mesurée km
est ce que nous dit l'intervalle de
confiance est bien c'est que sachant que
de notre échantillon
mesurer une taille moyenne de 1 m 65
nous pouvons en déduire que la taille
moyenne dans la population est situé
dans cet intervalle de confiance au tour
d'ahmed 65 tous les avantages des
sondages aléatoires c'est de pouvoir du
coup appliquer des formules statistiques
basées du coup sûr ces lois de
probabilité pour faire des tests de
comparaison ou pour faire des
intervalles de confiance
pour rappel le but des tests de
comparaison c'est de vérifier si les
observe les différences que j'observe
dans l'échantillon pourrait être
expliquée uniquement par le hasard de
l'échantillonnage ou bien si les
différences sont trop importantes pour
être expliquée uniquement par de mazars
de l'échantillonnage et donc du coup
qu'on peut en déduire quelque chose dans
la population d'origine
donc ça c'est le une spécificité de
toutes les enquêtes dans toutes les
enquêtes en fait on observe un
échantillon d'individus et on essaye du
cours d'en déduire des informations sur
la population qui est situé bien en eau
bien au-dessus alors on me dit qu'il ya
un petit prennent le micro est ce que là
vous m'entendez un peu mieux où le
volume est dit plus bas
merci de le signaler dans le chat ainsi
vous m'entendez bien donc en attente de
retour donc je vais continuer et donc à
mme donc la situation la plus simple
celle de base c'est l'enquète les
sondages aléatoires dit simple c'est à
dire qu'on va simplement tiré au sort
des individus et ce que l'on fait en
général c'est qu'on les tire au sort
avec on va tirer sur les individus avec
une probabilité que dans ce cas là c'est
le cas le plus simple c'est que dans ces
cas là qu'on se retrouve dans tout ce
qu'on a fait jusqu'à présent dans ce
qu'on a fait jusqu'à présent on a
considéré nos tests statistiques comme
relevant d'un échantillonnage aléatoire
simple ce qui peut se passer
ah c'est que c'est parfois nos
probabilités d'échantillonnage ne sont
pas les mêmes pour tout le monde et on
peut appliquer du coup un
échantillonnage avec des probabilités
d'échantillonnage inégale et donc du
coup certains individus en plus de
chances d'être recruté dans l' enquête
peu d'autres dans ces cas là on va
essayer de corriger notre échantillon
puisque on va sur représentés ceux qui
ont des probabilités d'échantillonnage
élevé et ceux qui ont des probabilités
d'échantillonnage faibles sont sous
représentées dans ces cas là on va
calculer des poids de pondération qui
sont en général
inversement proportionnelle à la
probabilité d'être inclus dans l'
enquête
ce qui fait que les individus qui
avaient peu de chances d'être inclus
dans l' enquête auront un poids plus
élevé et que ceux qui ont
chance importante d'être intrus dans l'
enquête auront un poids plus faible il
soin de corriger notre échantillon
parfois ces corrections ne sont pas
suffisantes et vous avez aussi un
certain temps kate on va procéder à ce
qu'on appelle un calage sur large c'est
à dire que supposons que dans mon
échantillon je me retrouve avec 60%
d'hommes et 40 % de femmes
or un recensement général de la
population me dis que dans la population
j'ai 51 % d'hommes pour sa 49 % de
femmes
on peut appliquer des coefficients de
pondération avec différentes techniques
de calcul pour rétablir la répartition
correct l'aube 7
donc on parle dans ces cas-là de calage
sur marge de pau stratification c'est
quelque chose d'assez fréquents dans les
grandes enquêtes et notamment dans les
enquêtes qui sont faites par l'insee ou
par l'ined en france et dans ces cas là
les poissons là pour corriger le fait
que certaines certains types d'individus
sont sont sous représentés les prêts de
pondération parfois sont calculés non
pas pour juste ajuster cette
représentation mais aussi pour permettre
d'avoir une meilleure estimation de la
population totale et donc on verra ça va
être un des exemples dans l'enquêté soir
où on a des poids qui nous indique en
fait le nombre d'individus dont la
population que la personne enquêtée va
représenter mais nos enquêtes peuvent
être aussi un petit peu plus complexe et
on a notamment dans les grands types des
sondages qui s'ils peuvent être
stratifié et ou en grappe le principe
d'un sondage en gras en strates pardon
ces deux d'éviter d'avoir à faire une
poste stratification supposons par
exemple que je nature et de mon
échantillon j'ai bien la bonne
proportion d'hommes et la bonne
proportion de femmes
ce que je peux faire c'est si jamais je
sais qu'il y à 51 % d'hommes et 49 % de
femmes dans la population et que je fais
une enquête sur 1000 personnes eh bien
je vais réaliser au lieu de faire un
seul échange un seul tirage au sort
aléatoire on va faire deux tirages au
sort 1 pour les hommes
il ya pour les femmes et je vais tirer
du coup au sort 510 homme et je vais
tirer au sort 490 femmes on peut faire
des strates plus complexes elles peuvent
être par groupes d'âge
dans certains cas elles peuvent être
faits entre le milieu de résidence par
exemple on va faire une stratification
milieu rural milieu urbain
ça peut se faire par différentes régions
le principe si qu'on divise notre
population selon une plusieurs variables
connu et ensuite on va faire des tirages
au sort
séparément pour chacune des strates dans
lequel plus simple ce que l'on va faire
c'est que le nombre de personnes qui
ressort dans chaque strate va
correspondre à la répartition connue à
l'avance de la population selon les
différentes strates parfois ce que l'on
peut faire aussi c'est décidé de se
représenter une strate
par exemple si je prends ici cet exemple
là on voit que la strate la troisième
strate elle il ya très peu de personnes
dedans et donc comme j'aimerais bien
qu'un avoir un minimum d'informations à
voir
s'ils ont suffisamment important dans ce
groupe là pour pouvoir par la suite
pourra faire des analyses par ce groupe
je pourrai décider d'augmenter le taux
de sélection dans cette strate là dans
ce cas là on a un échantillonnage en
strates avec les probabilités
d'inclusion différent pour chaque ligne
de ce tract ce qui n'est pas un problème
et simplement on va calculer dans les po
des poids de pondération qui vont tenir
compte de ces différences
d'échantillonnage le fait que certaines
strates sont sur représentés ou se
représenter pour équilibrer les
estimations globales un autre type d'
enquête ce sont les enquêtes en grappe
je vais prendre un cas de figure
supposons vous voulez faire une enquête
dans un pays nationale en population
générale est représentative
si jamais et supposons que vous ayez
accès à la liste du dernier recensement
de la population donc on a une base de
sondage exhaustive
supposons que le recensement est lui il
ya six mois on va se dire ça y est là
bas et je vais tirer au sort de manière
totalement aléatoire les personnes de
mon recensement ce qui se passe c'est
que du coup on va avoir des personnes
qui sont réparties sur tout le
territoire national et donc vous
imaginez que ça va être assez compliqué
de se déplacer au lieu de résidence de
tous ces individus
ça va coûter cher en temps en essence en
transport et donc ça risque d'être
compliqué de réaliser
l'anc est telle qu'elle est donc du coup
souvent ce qu'ils peuvent à être fait
dans des enquêtes nationales pour
simplifier la mise en oeuvre de l'en
tête c'est de faire un ultime ménage en
deux temps je vais d'abord tiré au sort
des zones de dénombrement pendant une
enquête à des petites zones
géographiques
et puis ensuite je vais tirer au sort
des individus dans ma zone de
dénombrement et donc du coup au lieu
d'avoir
si je fais une enquête sur 3000
personnes avec
200 g je n'aurai pas à me déplacer dans
trois milieux différents et dans
seulement deux mille lieux différents
une autre possibilité c'est si vous
faites une enquête auprès d'étudiants ou
des lèvres
je m'intéresse à cette population
d'élèves plutôt que de tirer au sort des
élèves en france on va d'abord tiré au
sort des départements donc je vais tirer
au sort dizaine de départements puis
dans chacun des départements je vais
tirer au sort des écoles puis ensuite
dans chaque école je vais tirer au sort
des classes et enfin jean qu'est très
tous les individus tous les élèves de
chacune des classes tirés au sort on est
encore une fois dans un échantillonnage
en grappe
mais cette fois ci on a parlé d'un
échantillonnage grappe à plusieurs
degrés premier degré je tire au sort des
départements deuxième degré je tire au
sort des écoles et au troisième degrés
je tire au sort des classes et enfin
dans mes classes
là pas de tirage au sort puisque je fais
une enquête qui est exhaustive donc ça
c'est ce qu'on va appeler un
échantillonnage on va le problème avec
un échantillonnage en grappe c'est que
souvent les individus d'une même grappe
vont avoir tendance à se ressembler tous
les élèves d'une même classe a du coup
ils ont une mamie milliers de résidences
ils ont le même contexte
on va dire des contextes de vie qui va
être à peu près similaires parce qu'ils
sont dans le même endroit et donc du
coup souvent les individus même grappe
ont tendance à se ressembler et donc du
coup on va perdre en estimation mais la
contrepartie c'est que onze ans son
agent grave on va faciliter
considérablement l'emplette et donc du
coup on va pouvoir faire des enquêtes
bien plus grande et souvent du coup le
gain en temps en organisation le gain
financier du sondage en grappe va
permettre de faire des échantillons bien
plus grand et donc du coup cette année
chantillon plus grande a permis de
gagner en précision
même si on en a perdu parfaite
faire d'échantillonnage en crabe plutôt
qu'un échantillonnage purement aléatoire
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est qu'on
peut combiner enquête en grappes et
enquêtes stratifié si je prends
l'exemple des enquêtes démographiques et
de santé alors pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas les enquêtes
démographiques et de santé un grand
programme d' enquêtes nationales
représentatives qui sont réalisés à
intervalles réguliers tous les cinq à
six ans dans la plupart des pays en
développement du monde
on a plus d'une centaine de pays qui
participent aux primes le ts et on
dispose de ts depuis maintenant une
trentaine voire une quarantaine d'années
pour certains pays les enquêtes eds ont
l'avantagé suivre une méthodologique est
similaire d'un pays à l'autre avec des
questionnaires qui sont standardisés ce
qui permet du coup de faire des
comparaisons dans l'espace mais aussi
dans le temps entre en quête d'un même
pays et en général il s'agit d' enquête
stratifié en grappe à 2 degrés pourquoi
d'une part l'enquêté va être ratifié par
milieu de résidence urbain et rural et
par grande région
par grandes régions c'est son nom va
découper le pays en cinq six grandes
régions le nord l'est l'ouest le centre
et donc on va comme on veut avoir
suffisamment de mots l'enquêté dans
chacune de ces régions pour pouvoir
faire des choses analyse le tirage le
premier tirage au sort ait ratifié par
une résidence et par région une fois
qu'on est dans ces régions est servi de
résidence on va tirer au sort des zones
de dénombrement au dernier recensement
et on ne le fait pas de manière
aléatoire ça on va tirer au sort avec
des probabilités qu'ils sont
proportionnelles au nombre de ménages
dans la zone de dénombrement au cours du
dernier recensement
les enquêteurs vont se rendre dans les
zones de dénombrement là ils vont
refaire cartographie de l'ensemble des
ménages
et on a ensuite un nouveau tirage au
sort
en règle générale on va tirer au sort
entre vingt et quarante et un enfants
suivant les enquêtes de ménage dans
cette zone de dénombrement et on enquête
alors tous ces ménages et les âmes et
les femmes qui on est donc sur une
enquête qui est en grappes et stratifié
et puis bien sûr du fait de tout le
système mis en place d'échantillonnage
les probabilités d'inclusion ne sont pas
les mêmes pour tous les individus et
donc vont être calculée des poids de
pondération qui tienne compte de ces
probabilités
donc on voit là on a plusieurs grands
types d' enquête
on va voir maintenant comment est-ce
qu'on peut prendre ça en compte dans
l'air ce qui est important à retenir
c'est qu'on ne peut pas se contenter des
poings liés et on fera un exemple tout à
l'heure pour montrer en quoi il y a un
impact du fait de définir des strates ou
des grappes ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les poids de pondération sont
suffisants pour calculer les proportions
et de moyenne
par contre le format de l'enquète ils
sont modestes frontier neige va avoir un
impact sur le calcul de la variance donc
sur le calcul des écarts types par
exemple et le calcul de la variance du
tout ce qui sera intervalle de confiance
tests statistiques et du coup tout ce
qui va être modélisation
d'où l'importance de bien prendre en
compte non seulement le plan
d'échantillonnage mais également de
prendre en compte la pas seulement la
pondération mais également le plan
d'échantillonnage pour ça il ya un
package de référence dont m et c'est le
parti du serveur
alors on va pour illustrer tout ça on va
créer un nouveau script la première
chose qu'on va faire passer on va me
donner un titre donc session 10 données
pondérées et plan d'échantillonnage
comme d'habitude un d'abord chargé des
données donc déjà on va charger le tag
diverses pour l'avoir sous la main on va
charger les chimères et notamment je
donnais hdv 2003 dont les fonctions qui
nous sert tout le temps aussi je m en
vais voir la belle pour pouvoir disposer
de la fonction d'oxford et puis surtout
on va charger le package savait alors
regardons rapidement hdv 2003 une
variable que nous n'avions pas regarder
jusqu'à présent c'est la marque table
[Musique]
bon invariable points notre enquête là
une variable poids et si je regarde le
jeu de données dans le viewer vous
verrez cette variable points ce qui est
important de noter ici c'est la valeur
élevée des poils pourriez les poires ils
sont de l'ordre de 2634 9538 12 1891
11040 de ski donc là on a des bois qui
des poids qui sont particulièrement
élevées et sa mère qui est un peu de
stratégie donc dans les enquêtes
vous avez soit des points de correction
est ce que font les producteurs de
l'enquète ils vont y vont ensuite mettre
à niveau les poids pour que la somme de
tous les poids correspondent à la somme
des observations
pour rappel d'un fichier hdv 2003 nous
avons 2000 individus donc dans ce cas là
si on veut être dans cette première
approche on prendrait tous les poids qui
on est
pelé et on les dit viseraient par la
somme de tous les poids et on
multiplierait par de mire l'idée c'est
juste de faire une règle de trois pour
s'assurer que le total des points
correspondent en observation dans
d'autres enquêtes et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut toujours se référer à ce qu'ont
fait les producteurs de l'enquète et
d'avoir une connaissance fine de la
documentation associée de l'enquète
lespwa vont représenter la somme des
points va correspondre à la somme à la
taille de la population dont est issu
l'anc est donc si je fais si je fais ici
la somme variable points vous voyez ici
la somme des poids fait 11 millions 61
1071 1226 pour rappel l'enquète algérie
2003 la les données qui en sont
extraites je crois sont sourds juste une
sous-partie la france est pas toute la
france on n'est que sur les 18 ans et
plus et donc du coup ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la dent l'enquète
on a fait un tirage au sort dans une
population dont la taille est connu et
qui est de 11 millions d'individus et
donc du coup les pois ont été calculés
de manière à ce que leurs seuls
correspondent à la population totale
tout d'où sont issus les individus ont
quitté et donc ce que la manière dont
121 interpréter ses pointes du fait des
plans des jeunes et des variations les
probabilités sections qui sont
différentiel c'est que du coup ce que
nous dit le poids c'est que cette femme
de 71 ans ici en fait elles représentent
4329 individus de la population totale
tandis que cet homme de 47 ans lui va
représenter 12 1891 individus ce qu'il
faut bien noter ici c'est que les pois
ne dise pas que services d'installation
c'est juste ce que représente lundi
nu et on va voir que du coup ça a un
impact sur un certain nombre de calculs
alors dans le fichier hdv 2003 on n'a
pas d'informations sur le fait de savoir
si jamais c'est une enquête qui est
savoir est ce que c'est une enquête qui
serait
pour d'airé de savoie apparent sinon
quelle stratégie ou en grappe donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est par défaut on va
considérer que c'est une enquête savoir
le cas de figure si c'est une enquête on
a que les points on n'a donc ni strates
ni grave
est ce que je vais faire je vais créer
quelques variables aléatoires juste pour
simulent des cas de figure qu'on aurait
une variable qui contiendrait des
stratégies graal pour voir les impacts
que ça sur nos différents calculs donc
là je vais cibler des strates et donc ce
qu'on va faire pour jouer du crime
variable ces tracts d'accord et je lui
dis je vais je m je vais faire 4-4
groupe de 500 à chaque fois pour
simplifier le 10 mai 2003 strates donc
par défaut c'est à je vais dire qu'entre
les lignes 1 800 et on admire individus
et 1999
cb et enfin entre 1200 et 2000 cc
je suis passé en sur une syntaxe
classique de m donc là je crie ma le
strat qui vaut à puis je dis que pour
les valeurs 800 à 2199 j'applique b et
pour les valeurs mine de soins de piles
j'applique sait si j'avais fait un
tableau de fréquences oui et j'ai obtenu
du coup quatre groupes 27 199 individus
24 100es en 800 je vais créer enfin un
des grappes alors là l'idée ça va être
de se dire que on va considérer qu'on
est là et qu'on a eu recours à 25 luster
donc si j'ai recours à 25 luster
c'est-à-dire 2000 / 25
on va considérer que nous avons 25
cluster différent de 80 individus chacun
je vais créer très rapidement cette
variable en disant que je prends les
numéros 1 25 et que je vais répéter ses
crêpes conscient et c'est un taxi je
veux très points 1 pour répéter certains
chiffres une certain nombre de fois
d'égal 80 donc si je répète la séquence
de chiffres
1 2 3 4 5 jusqu'à 25 81 x j'obtiens bien
un vecteur de 2000 et donc du coup je
vais créer ma variable si je fais mon
tableau de fréquences
donc j'ai bien à chaque fois 20 g
numérotées de 1 à 25 à chaque fois 80
personnes de dons ce qui est à retenir
c'est juste un de vue-là je le fais de
manière je vais être singulier ça sera
plus propre
donc je fais ça juste ces deux variables
qui sont virtuelles mais que je vais
utiliser pour les exemples maintenant on
va voir comment définir un plan
d'échantillonnage avec servait et pour
ça il a une fonction internet c'est la
fonction usb if design et je vous
présente tout de suite son fichier
d'elle donc la fonction et ce design
il faut déjà une première variable ds
qui va indiquer les différentes crap du
fichier cluster en anglais et vous
pouvez indiquer simplement type 2 1
vous allez voir c'est une syntaxe en
termes de formule si jamais il n'y a pas
de cluster pour a besoin c'est
une variable qui indique les
probabilités d'inclusion si jamais en
fournit les probabilités d'inclusion des
individus alors vous aurez le paquet va
tout seul calcul et des poids de
pondération si vous avez des potes
pondération dans ce cas là la variable
wales pour indiquer votre valable poids
et du coup il n'y a pas besoin de
fournir propre strata sait si votre
fichier est stratifié vous pouvez du
coup indiquer le nom de la variable qui
contient votre stratification et puis
enfin vous avez un paramètre fpc qui est
fini de population correctionne vous
avez détail dessus mais si vous avez des
échantillonnages à partir d'une petite
population peut rajouter des corrections
supplémentaires en indiquant la taille
de la population globale tout en haut
alors v10 fille et une fois qu'on a ça
la fonction 2010 à il va nous renvoyer
un objet qui n'est plus un data fremm
était une sorte de data qui ce qu'on
appelle un sauvé design ici un objet qui
contient un jeu de données avec les
informations d'échantillonnage et j'ai
donc créé vachon créer 3 - même quatre
pour vous je m'en créer 3 un cas de
figure on a juste des poids un cas de
figure avec des strates
un cas de figure avec des grappes et en
cas de figure avec des strates et des
grappes
je vous rappel pour ceux qui sont
arrivés en cours de route les strates
c'est quand on a séparé notre population
d'origine en plusieurs sous groupes et
on a ensuite échantillonnés séparément
dans chaque strate et les grappes
c'est le cas de figure on va faire un
tirage au sort en plusieurs temps et on
va par exemple tire au sort des zones
géographiques puis des établissements
puis des individus dans l'établissement
quand c'est quand on fait un tirage au
sort étape par étape
alors
si on ami graphiste rate maintenant je
vais faire je vais appeler des pour
donner w pour ponte pour will titre
pendez les données pondérées dp et donc
s by design dans le cas de figure où je
n'ai ni strates ni grave je vais indiqué
t-il d'1 ha et ds le premier paramètre
pour ça permet de dire qu'il n'ya pas de
grave j'ai mariable de pondération qui
est poids donc je vais indiquer waits et
ce cas attendus dont elle vit design
c'est la variable sont indiqués sous
forme d'une formule 1 on les avait vus
pour les modèles 1 s'est-il dont la
variable et je vais simplement rajouté
d'actes à égal hdv 2003 voici un objet
dp par défaut là ça va être un nid n'est
pas un homme simple in design avec
remplacement si on avait donné une
correction fini on aurait pu tenir
conquis et par emplacement les
changements si votre enquête est petite
par rapport à une population très grande
de plusieurs millions ça va pas changer
grand chose dans notre cas de figure on
peut aller plus en détail
encore une fois n'hésitez
sinon la documentation de l'enquète que
vous avez que vous avez fait supposons
on est maintenant une enquête stratifié
donc donné pour dire et avec des strates
sv design toujours idée est égale 1
car je n'ai pas de poster j'indique mais
point waits égale poids data dylan hdv
2003 si je regarde ce que j'obtiens des
strates c'est donc vous l'avez ici avec
du coude et des tirages au sort pour
chacun distract pardon j'ai pas mis la
strate quelque chose et donc ce tract à
égal et id est la variable en question
s'est du coup ce tract vous voyez
l'allemagne est bien gentil fight sangin
voir le cas de figure d'une enquête qui
serait en grappe mais non stratifié donc
là cette fois ci c s by design toujours
les grappes de mehdi en fait ca id est
ce qu'on va les vallées passé et donc du
coup je vais mettre le nom de la
variable moi j'applique gras par
simplicité
j'indique mais poids
et data ingram hdv 2000 points et enfin
on va faire un jeu de données qui est en
grappes et stratifié donc tu rates big
rap est donc là je vais rajouter ici à
la fois le paramètre id s il part ahmad
strata
à avenches aucun souci pour le oui parce
que des clusters qui sont pas dans les
strates énormément les pasteurs sont
dans les strates ce qui pose problème
pour le test
allard a tant donné je sais ce qu'on va
faire et juste rechange et un rapidement
la manière de faire les choses
je vais commencer par cris kloster
ensuite je vais trier hdv 2003 on va le
crier
par grappes et je vais le crime est
valable strates
[Musique]
si je fais ça je regarde rapidement le
hd vidéo que j'ai obtenue à la toute fin
j'ai bien des strates qui sont mes
craintes sont bien à l'intérieur d'une
même strate donc m'excusant ça c'était
sur la partie simulation de cearà z
frappe et maintenant on va recréer nos
différents objets et pourquoi ça ne
marche pas on va faire un tableau croisé
de fonction et a permis de faire des
tableaux croisés jeux et les sommets
avec la fonction tilda variable une
variable 2 je vais faire graver une
strate va pas égales page dv 2003 il est
ici qui est un petit souci on va aller
là sur lui et il y en a un qui calais en
un
parce qu'ici il faut que j'aille à 1200
si je fais ça on va refaire le tableau
croisé donc là j'ai bien des graves
à l'intérieur de ce tract ce qui est
important de retenir c'est que quand on
est sur un échantillonnage qui est il ya
une vérification qui a été faite à la
conférence etc sur un échantillonnage
stratifié en grave c'est qu'on commence
par faire on fait le tirage au sort des
grappes au sein de chacune des strates
et donc du coup normalement nos grappes
sont bien situés au sein de strates pour
revenir sur les big design vous voyez
que là on arrive assez facilement à
définir un point d'échantillonnage
qu'ils soient stratifié en grappe ou
stratifier et en grappe
ce qui est important c'est de bien
savoir quelle est la variable qu'on
associé à quel endroit
une petite info c'est pour un
échantillonnage un échantillonnage à
plusieurs degrés on aurait un premier
niveau qui serait senti dans une
variable niveau 1 et un deuxième niveau
dans une variable niveau 2 on peut
indiquer du coup plusieurs niveaux avec
farrar plus bas que 1 donc ici si on
avait une de niveau cap c'est à dire par
exemple un tirage au sort
d'établissements publics l'âge me remmy
les deux variables séparées par un plus
haï ds pour indiquer qu on est sur un
échantillonnage à plusieurs devant le
gros avantage c'est que et on va le voir
un peu plus tard quand on fait des
calculs il ya plein de correction
différentes à apporter suivant cas de
figure suivants si c'est une tradition
aussi scénographe et ainsi de suite
et en fait non n'aura pas du tout à son
occuper une fois qu'on a des films notre
plan d'échantillonnage correctement
c'est les mêmes fonctions qu'on va
utiliser tous du londres et servait à
tout seul gérer les différentes
corrections nécessaires dans les
différents types de calculs pour celles
et ceux d'entre vous qui ont eu des
cours de théorie des sondages
normalement
[Musique]
il ya un gros travail de les formules
qu'on applique pour ce coup c'est court
la toiture et des sondages de correction
des calculs de variance et des formules
à rallonge
moi je vous avoue je me suis toujours
perdu là ce qu'il faut retenir c'est du
produit pragmatique avec servait une
fois que les choses sont définis servait
va tout seul gérer les différentes
corrections nécessaires au talent requis
alors ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
l'objet qu'on a maintenant c'est
l'envers que nous renvoient servait
c'est plus un tableau de données si je
regarde sa structure alors si j'avais
view de dp
voyez l'objet en arbre en fait une liste
qui contient plusieurs informations
contient un premier objet kloster avec
en fait les informations sur le
clustering un 2e objet strata qui
contient les informations sur les
strates là y'en a pas donc du coup c'est
un partout et puis en fait les varion en
tant que tel le jeu de données
il est contenu dans un sous-ensemble qui
s'appelle variable donc en fait il est
possible d'accéder à certaines variables
et sur un objet serveurs on peut
utiliser la syntaxe crochet c'est une
des toutes premières vidéos qu'on a vu
avec la mérule par exemple dp3 permet
d'accéder à la 3e ligne est donc on peut
faire des corrections mais c'est pas
forcément ce qu'il ya de plus pratique
pour manipuler et donc s'il ya un
conseil essentiel
c'est fait tout les reconnais fication
avant donc travailler sur votre si je
donnais en tongs data femme de ménage
classique fait tout les reconnais
fication avant de définir le plan
d'échantillonnage le plan la définition
du plan d'échantillonnage se fera juste
avant la partie analytique d'accord donc
faites vos records d'avant et seulement
après vous pouvez définir votre plan
d'échantillonnage
sinon ça devient relativement compliqué
notre objet ses revers on l'a vu il
contient différentes informations et ce
qui est important aussi c'est de définir
le plan d'échantillonnage sur le jeu de
données entier si on a besoin d'un
sous-échantillon par exemple pour faire
l'analyse que parmi les femmes et bien
définir toujours définir l'objet serait
sur le table entier puis on pour
appliquer la fonction ce set
alors la faune succèdent c'est une
fonction que générique on avait déjà vu
rapidement s'observe c'est une fonction
qui permet d'extraire c'est une fonction
de base de r qui permet d'extraire juste
certaines observations c'est un peu un
équivalent du filter 2 10 plats hier et
par exemple si je voudrais un joug qui
contiennent que les femmes eh bien on
fera ce obsède
j'indique mon objet servette j'ai créé
et qui s'appelle donc des baies et lundi
qu'une condition les assez sexy
gallicane femmes
si vous regardez l'objet des biffins
qu'on obtient c'est toujours un plan
d'échantillonnage complexe sur un plus
petit groupe là dessus alors oui j'aime
y ait sans une observation mais ça a
transmis en fait les différentes
informations sur l'échantillonnage si
vous faites view bp femme ça a gardé les
informations sur le plus torride sur les
strates sur les probabilités en fait
tout ce qui est nécessaire on calcule
donc retenez fait votre définition
globale puis vous sous vous extrayez un
nouvel objet ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les viable de diplômes ne marche pas
sur les objets servait donc c'est
retenez bien pourquoi je disais tout à
l'heure on a un objet on a un tableau
n'est en fait tout l'art au code et
ensuite quand on va avoir besoin de
faire de l'analyse et de prendre en
compte les poids et le plan
d'échantillonnage à ce moment là on va
définir votre objet sauvé
donc pour extraire un sous-échantillon
on aura recours à la fonction s'observe
ici un moment donné on a besoin de
récupérer les points on pourra avoir
recours à la fonction royale
si je fais weitz de dp ce tract ça me
renvoie un vecteur des points donc ça ça
peut être intéressant si on ne se
souvient plus quelle est la période qui
les contenait aussi ça a été recalculé
d'une autre manière
wade permet de récupérer les peaux
maintenant ce que je vous propose c'est
de voir en quoi c'est essentiel
d'utiliser servait et qu'on veut pas se
contenter des poids de pondération et on
va vous et pourquoi en fait qu ce même
s'il ya des fonctions qui propose des
poids c'est pas forcément suffisant donc
on va faire un tableau croisé et un test
du kit 2
alors vous verrez soir un certain nombre
de fonctions celles capables de la
fonction j'ai élèves la fonction
hellemmes
ou encore quand on veut faire des
tableaux la fonction iq stable une des
fonctions qui permet de faire des
tableaux permettent de définir des
poissons d'un paramètre poids sur la
documentation nous indique comment
est-ce qu'on peut définir un point et
donc du coup alors mine pour la moyenne
ne permet pas de définir à poil vous
trouverez des fonctions comme whiting
mines et je crois d'ailleurs que aux
actionnaires on propose plusieurs
waiting mines et fourni de base avant
les stats et vous trouverez les deux
versions wade soit de base horaire soit
soit dans notre package ce qui permet du
coup d'utiliser des poids de pondération
dans le calcul de la moyenne d'autres
éléments
sauf que on va le voir c'est pas
forcément suffisante dès lors qu'on va
commencer à faire des intervalles de
confiance ou des thèmes statistiques je
vais vous proposer
là on va croiser la variable sport est
la variable sexe simplement oulhadj en
appareils de cuisine pour changer et on
va faire le tableau croisé pondérer avec
un objet d'art dont des tableaux des
classiques pondérer avec les quatre avec
servait donc si je le fais en mode
classique je parle recours à 6 tab donc
x times la vie on a deux fonctions de
base pour faire des tableaux croisés
dans air sans passer par judy somalie
sehic stade était bon c'est bon on y
passe directement une
un vecteur hextadon lui passe une
formule d'accord et donc si je veux
faire le tableau croisé deux sexes en
fonction de la cuisine j'indique que je
veux donc la formule c'est hilde sexe
plus cuisine et j'indique total de
données data égal à genève et 2003 et
vous obtenez le tableau croisé l'allant
pondérer si je veux indiquer que j'ai
une pondération
je vais tout simplement utiliser la
variable de poids donc ici là s'appelle
proche des jeunes indiqué avant le tilt
dans les stades
si je vais st j'obtiens bien mon tableau
alors vous avez vu on a des poids qui
sont qui va lille 2010 me l'a donc mon
total en fait ils ont tendance millions
mais j'ai bien mon tableau croisé
je vais l'affiché ici et si je veux
affiche y verra après comment gère tout
ça avec l'élitisme et oui mais si je me
l'affiché simplement des pourcentages
ici en ligne 1
vous avez air propre d'un questionnaire
que l'on passe à un tableau et qui nous
affichent des pourcentages en ligne tout
ça vous retrouverez sur l'analyseur
c'est juste que tu aurais bien que là on
est sur les fonctions de base pour faire
nos statistiques et qui donc là j'ai
bien des pourcentages et il semble que
les hommes et les femmes
[Musique]
on pas la même probabilité de pratiquer
depuis la cuisine 1 52 % des femmes
déclarent pratiquer la cuisine contre
seulement 31 % des hommes
et si jamais je veux vérifier que ces
différences significatives on peut faire
un test du chi 2 et ça se fait avec la
fonction qui secoua test à laquelle on
passe un tableau croisé
si je fais ça j'ai une paix valeur qui
va être extrêmement petit et m'a pris
valeur est extrêmement petit parce que
vous voyez le total de mon tableau c'est
en millions et quand je passe tableau
acquis square test qui secouèrent test
lui ne sait pas que c'est des points
pour lui c'est simplement des nombre
d'observations et donc du coup ils
considèrent que c'est un tableau
calculée sur 11 millions d'individus
donc forcément tout de suite toutes les
valeurs sont extrêmement petit ce qui
fait que notre résultat est complètement
biaisé parce qu'on n'a pas calculé sur
un million d'individus en calcul sur
2000 observations on a une marge
d'incertitude sur ce test c'est pour ça
que lorsque l'on applique en fait des
données pondérées directement à des
fonctions de test ou d'intervalle la
confiance ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
claude dans ces fonctions là le poids
est considéré comme ça va être comptés
comme des observations malines donc ici
la somme des points fait 11 millions
c'est interprété par la fonction qui
squattent est comme nous avons 11
millions d'observations
on va refaire du coup la même chose avec
les données pondérées dans deux c'est
vrai c'est juste que du coup pour faire
notre tableau on va pas pouvoir utiliser
directement à
la fonction iq stable mais on va devoir
passer par différentes fonctions
fournies par le paquet serait même la
plupart de ses fonctions commence par sv
y est on a entre autres la fonction et
ce véritable qui va permettre de faire
notre tableau cette fois ci notre
tableau csv it et bon jeu verdict et
sexe plus cuisine
alors vous voyez le deuxième paramètre
s'appelle pas data mais design pour dire
que ce qui l'attend c'est un objet s vie
design et là je vais dire des armes est
donné pour d'airé 100 grappillent
strates et si j'affiche mon tableau
j'obtiens un tableau est exactement le
même ne fut qu on avait tout à l'heure
16 millions soit 1 million 600 6297 oui
pour les hommes à minuit dix ans de 1987
oui pareil ici donc un je vous l'avais
dit dès poids son client compte je peux
appliquer leur propre également j'ai
bien mais pourcentage ici en ligne par
contre pour le test qui 2 on a une autre
fonction que la fonction sv qui
secouèrent est qu'il ne va pas prendre
du coup le résultat mais qui va en fait
prendre la formule
croisés si le fait un test du kit 2 ici
voyez j'ai pu m'en 0 1 x 10 puissance
moins 16 la différence est très marquée
et maintenant qu'elle est bien visible
mais voyez j'ai une paire valeur de 5,7
x 10 puissance moins 14 on est toujours
sur quelque chose qui est clairement
significatif mais ça a bien pris en
compte le fait qu'on avait que deux
mille observation ce qui se voit avec ce
monde 2° liberté l'issic et 1999 et 2000
- 1
on est du coup sûr la thèse de tubes qui
2 qui est aussi content de notre
pondération mais qui sait que le haut
c'est un test qui est fait sur 2000
observations qu'il ya eu des corrections
qui ont été ajustés au test du kit 2 et
plus précisément vous avez des
corrections selon les travaux de hao
scott
alors si vous êtes intéressés vous
pouvez alors le détail parce qu'en fait
tous les tests pourraient être réajusté
et vous avez dans l'aide et 8 qui
squattent est tous les travaux et les
références bibliographiques qui vous
explique comment commencer corriger et
s'est notamment basé sur les travaux de
respect à 2584 vous avez toutes les
références bibliographiques si vous êtes
intéressés pour aller plus loin en
détail ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
c'est un test du kit 2 ajusté est
adaptée au contexte d'un plan
d'échantillonnage complet et voyez le
résultat est pas le même alors sur
d'autres la sur la cuisine la différence
est assez marquée mais est ce qu'il y
aurait d'autres variables si je prends
le sport plutôt que la cuisine d'accord
on va refaire l'analyse avec sport
je reprends le premier tableau sans
prendre en compte le plan
d'échantillonnage est juste en
appliquant les pois forcément vous avez
une pvr qui est extrêmement petit 30
millions d'observations
si je fais la même chose maintenant ici
avec ma carte est certes appelé valeur
est toujours significative 1 35% de
femmes qui vont du sport contre 44 %
d'hommes mais voyez en n&b valeurs qui
nous est revenue 00 42 et si on prend
d'autres variables
quand on avance millions d'individus
votes requis de il est systématiquement
l'équipe rlr qui est infinitésimal alors
que si on a vu un échantillon bien plus
petit peut-être qu'on ne verrait pas
d'effet donc l'importance de prendre en
compte correctement tout ça va avoir un
impact pour ne pas conclure à tort un
effet que l'on fait on n'observe pas du
tout et là on a juste pris en compte les
points
il n'y a pas d'accord défait de grappes
ou de strates qui sont qui sont rajoutés
vous voyez juste prendre en compte les
pouvoirs sans tenir compte en fait de ce
que représentent ces points là on arrive
à des erreurs les poissons considérer
enfin en fait les poids dans les
fonctions de base ça veut dire que tu es
l'observation doit être compté deux fois
trois fois quatre fois l'an fait c'est
parce qu'on aurait les données qui vous
n'aurez fusionner des opérations là avec
servair où on va correctement pour un
goûter éviter de faire des
interprétations peuvent maintenant est
ce que le fait d'avoir des strates des
crabes change nos résultats donc
supposons que je regarde maintenant le
tableau où on obtient avec une enquête
en rap je remonte le tableau qu'on avait
avant le tableau avec temps 4 vous voyez
les tableaux sont tout à fait identique
les points sont utilisés et donc du coup
il n'y a pas de différence dans le
calcul des moyennes et des proportions
c'est simplement les points qui vont
jouer par contre si je fais mon test du
chi 2 dans le cas d'une enquête en
grappe
je vous remets le kid de son enquête
dont là vous voyez que j'ai pas du tout
les mêmes des valeurs s'il n'y avait pas
de grappes on était à une valeur de 0
004 et avec ligne avec les grappes les
jeunes pères et leurs qui est maintenant
de 0,002 bon le fait d'avoir des grappes
peut modifier mes calculs et mettait
statistiques et les valeurs à la hausse
ou à la baisse
d'où l'importance de pouvoir les tester
si je fais si je regarde maintenant le
résultat avec un échantillon stratifié
j'ai encore une autre valeur et si je
prends l'échantillon stratifié est en
grave j'ai encore une autre des valeurs
donc ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que le
fait que l'échantillon se stratifie nous
connaissons pichon l'échantillon soit en
grappe va avoir un impact plus des
valeurs parce que du coup et des
corrections qui doit être fait et
notamment quand il ya des crêpes on va
regarder s'il ya des effets un travail
et un thème trappe
parfois les différences on va être peu
important parfois ça va carrément
changer vos conclusions
d'où le fait que c'est essentiel de bien
défini
la présence des grappes et la présence
et la présence des strates
alors c'est vrai que travailler des
données ce revers et complique un peu
les choses parce que tous les tests
change il faut du coup des versions
adaptées au plan d'échantillonnage
complexe des enquêtes
dd il faut du coup effectivement des
versions adaptées de tous les tests mais
la bonne nouvelle c'est que jti samarie
est compatible avec les objets serveurs
et donc on va voir c'est la fonction tv
rsv se marient la fonction t bns
veillissement lui fonctionne comme la
fonction se marient qu'on avait été
belle série qu'on avait déjà vu sauf que
elle s'applique à des objets de type
survey alors je vais prendre je prends
des p o
je vais appliquer tbl sbx varient comme
je veux pas avoir toutes les variables
je vais rajouter une plus ni d'un avec
une liste variables à prendre en compte
dans le tableau de classe qu'il va
m'intéresser sénat variable sexe navale
le sport et d'avaya de cuisine ici je
fais cela j'obtiens bien le tri à plat
des différentes variables les poissons
correctement prise en compte pour le
calcul des pourcentages on peut
également rajouter avec bail d'une
variable de croisement
par exemple un tableau qui sépare les
hommes et les femmes en termes de
pourcentage
vous pourriez aussi décider de ne
représenter que les pourcentages et pas
les effectifs dans ce cas là en dix ans
n'est plus la somme des points ne fait
pas forcément sens pour les individus
parce que ce qui m'intéresserait plus
tôt à nombre d'observations d'accord
alors simon vient des leds petit billet
sbx mairie
pour rappel ces statistiques qui permet
qui permet de dire qu'est ce qu'on veut
afficher et si vous avez dans l'aide
vous verrez que dans le cas présent on a
un peu plus de choses que vous avez les
effectifs mais aussi des versions non
pondéré donc je pourrais dire que
statistiques égales pour les variables
catégorique ce que je veux affiche et
c'est dommage
le pourcentage donc ces petits pets et
entre parenthèses j'afficherai
simplement le nombre d'observations et
donc cette fois ci je veux du coût des
observations donc ça va être le petit n
nippon verrez m wanted si j'exécute ceux
ci là j'ai bien un tableau avec mes
pourcentage est en fait ce que j'avais
dit que c'est mais non d'observation
[Musique]
on peut aussi si l'on souhaite modifier
les en tête de colonne puisque les
antennes de colonnes nous indiquant fait
par défaut le grand thème c'est à dire
les le nombre total en fait c'est la
somme des poids et donc pas le nombre
d'observations et on a pour cela si je
me trompe pas modify leader angers qui
se marient qui peut permettre du coup de
modifier alors regardez les exemples qui
permet de contrôler et de contrôler un
peu plus comment on affiche est par
exemple vous avez voilà ce n'est ici le
maudit fanni d'heure update au stade
comme une variable de colonnes et on
indique comment est-ce qu'on veut
représenter ça si j'apprends de ce
morceau de code
donc on se met ici pourcentage
pourcentage modified heures donc updates
ça veut dire je vais indications l'école
que je mettre à jour moi ce que je veux
au stade comme ça va permettre de
sélectionner les colonnes qui présente
ici un des résultats et donc je veux
mettre nl1000 ty et si on fait ça
j'ai mis à jour par contre j'ai pas
envie de m'aider pourcentage d'ici donc
on va supprimer simplifiée donc mais
l'insee donc le niveau il est double *
ici on sait pour dire comble du grain
arias qui doivent être les informations
indiquées entre crochets et vous avez du
coup un tableau mis à jour on a comme
pour thil ils se marient la possibilité
de rajouter un ado vole un stade chaud
pour le mettre à la fin donc je peux
rajouter une colonne total voiliers qui
si makoun total à l'eau mais la somme
des poids si encore si on veut à
afficher le nombre d'observations plutôt
classe habité poids et bien on va
regarder 22 h au pôle on doit avoir un
exemple sur comment ça se met à jour à
peut-être qu'il faut mettre le ados vol
avant le maudit fanni d'heure ou à pied
alors c'est pas ça comment est-ce qu'on
peut personnaliser le total satin modify
leaders sur
alors si je sauve sa dans un tableau un
jeu mais après ça tu es b hop on affiche
tb ça va me permettre de voir comment
est structuré tv alors tb tam body
métadatas donc ça ça les métadonnées tb
vers le body pour cuisines à cet appel
stat 0
voilà la colonne qui nous intéresse
c'est stat 0 dans un stade un
pourcentage de 0 sél les totaux et donc
du coup nous pour faire un dix failles
leader updates légal stat 0 qui sera
donc légal
c'est une totale d'un bull m
wild side
non ça se mange pas ou c'est dans le
labo mais il n'y a pas besoin de
connaître tous par coeur moi même je
n'arrive pas à me souvenir de tout ce
que je sais c'est qu'en cherchant dans
l'aisne en général on arrive à trouver à
il est ici le défaut c'est comme
l'appelle en fait il faut mettre
ajoutez en fait on a deux rôles si je
rajoute comme label égal à nos rôles et
je pense que cette haine nourrie ty mais
avec le grand thème on va vérifier et
voilà les convives en chaque chant est
donc le dernier point je voulais vous
montrer c'est le fait qu'on peut
rajouter du coup les tests statistiques
et si on rajoute
ap
vous l'avez du coup les tests
statistiques et vous voyez que c'est un
test du kit 2 avec les corrections du
second tour de raul scops si on veut
plus d'informations vous pouvez aller
sur net de hp
alors oui il ya un aspect pourrait tv al
samaoui et 1 ap pour tbs vis ma vie à
deux entrées et ed
je vais regarder l'entrée dead pour la
version us vis ma vie
et là vous y verrez les différents tests
qui sont possibles et voiliers on n'a
que des tests adaptés aux objets de type
servait si vous voulez un test des coûts
par exemple de moyenne il ya une version
usb et est particulière vous avez des
tests de rang au besoin vous devez
revoir ici avec les bonnes fonctions cs
virenque test de ce revers le test de
crosby wallis adapté dont vous voyez le
test de comparaison de médiane le test
du kit 2 vous avez un tabou qui devait
ajuster si vous voulez voir un peu plus
plus d'informations vous avez là c'est
des variations autour du test du kit 2
vous avez c'est le principal c'est celle
qu'on a vue et parce qu'effectivement
salt est celui qui deux cantons car
l'aide là plusieurs ajustements
différend autour d'eux qu'ils sont
possibles soit vous avez temps
d'explorer tout ça soit si on prenait
les versions par défaut quoi qu'il en
soit ce qu'il faut retenir c'est dès
qu'on a un objet servait on doit adapter
toutes vos fonctions on doit adapter
l'ensemble des tests mais aujourd'hui ça
devient relativement plus facile
notamment parce que sv issa marie
fonction alors je reviens rapidement les
commentaires avant continuer
il ya une question qui est posée de
savoir si l'on divise les poids par la
taille de la population obtient pour les
bonnes peuvent à l'heure pour les états
unis 2 au delà du plan d'échantillonnage
et bien non on peut faire un petit test
rapide
[Musique]
supposons que je fasse des va faire des
points corrigé donc je vais rajouter
moi je dévie 2003 il variables clés
points 2 qui sera donc idéal au poids
divisé par la somme des points
et x venir si on fait un résumé cette
nouvelle variante le point hdv 2003 de
la ve on a des points qui m'ont envoyé
au président de 0,1 et 5,6 et si on
regarde la somme des poids on a donc des
points dont la symbole le nombre
d'observations
alors que se passe-t-il lorsqu'on
calcule ici je vais refaire tableaux
croisés mais j'ai utilisé pour annuler
si je prends ces nouveaux poids
j'obtiens du coup les malheurs il il ya
des noms qui apparaissent mais des
observations donc en totale fait plus
sens et si je regarde le tableau en
pourcentage
j'obtiens les mêmes chiffres et tout à
l'heure si je compare avec donc je
servais lorsqu'on regarde le tableau en
pourcentage avec ces nouveaux emplois ça
ne change rien
que se passe-t-il lorsqu'on fait le test
du kit 2 là je fais un test du chi 2
avec ckoi corrigé j'obtienne paix valeur
de 7,5 118 x 10 puissance moins 6 je
fais mon test du kit de avec le poids de
régime est défini dans ses oreilles
j'obtiens une autre valeur en fait ça
renvoie la même chose c'est que ça ne ça
ne modifie pas fondamentalement la
planète en fait on aurait un autre
résultat lorsqu'on va
et puis ce qui doit avec ses poils à en
approche classique
en fait le fait d'ajuster de normaliser
les poids sur la taille de l'échantillon
ne règle pas le problème du calcul qui 2
alors quand même juste pour vous montrer
supposons que je fasse un objet dp2 je
passe avec servait et que j'utilise ces
poids c'est pour ajuster dans l'objet
db2 est-ce que ça par coup le changement
de peau l'homme va avoir un impact sur
le calcul avec servair donc là j'ai le
calcul 1 avec mes poids d'origine là
avec une fois normaliser les résultats
ici sont identiques
donc quand on organise les poids pour
servais ça va pas changer les résultats
servent à s'adapter
voyez j'ai la même valeur que j'ai les
pointes auto ou les pois normalisée
quand je passe par servais j'ai bien des
résultats qui sont cohérents qui ne
dépendent pas du coup du niveau
normalisation des points ce qui montre
bien qu'il fallait passer par servais
pour prendre ça correctement en compte
alors que si je passe par interviews
croisées classique et j'applique un kid
ou classique et bien j'ai des résultats
différents suivant les pointes au tour
n'est pas normalisée et qui sont de
toute façon des résultats encore
différent de ce que j'avais avec servair
alors je suis pas un spécialiste des
parcs 10 titien ou je suis un
utilisateur des statistiques mais
vraiment s'il ya quelque chose à retenir
c'est qui je n'ai pas toutes les
fonctions ce qui est à retenir c'est
qu'en tout cas c'est pas une si pâle ou
une petite c'est pas une des petites aux
actions en fait qu'il est proposé et que
c'est vraiment préférable de passer par
sa ordinaire alors il y avait une
question sur comment peut-on faire des
estimations par quel âge aux marges dans
l'est alors je ne vais pas vous
présenter l'un
soit c'est quelque chose de plus
compliqué si vous voulez faire vous même
décalage sur marge c'est possible dans
air toujours avec survey et c'est je
retrouve le nom de la fonction pour st
parce que du coup c'est en fait ya
plusieurs manières de calculer des
poules canards sauvages
l'insee en france utilise en fait une
macro qu'ils ont développés eux mêmes
sous sas les différents instituts des
statistiques ons un peu leur propre
manière de le faire est sous céreq sous
terre on peut le faire avec la fonction
wake sachant qu'il faut savoir quelle
différence entre un calage son marges et
une post ratification mais vous avez du
coup de fonction wake les vous avez vous
premières données avec la pondération de
base avant 15h sur marge et vous allez
devoir fournir en fait un tableau de
données avec les les valeurs de calage
je vais pas aller plus loin aujourd'hui
mais sachez que ça se passe là dedans et
vous avez aussi une fonction post hâtif
et donc je vous invite à regarder du
comté de wake si vous voulez réaliser
vos propres calage sur marge mais ça
nécessite un minimum de bagage et de
savoirs et de savoir ce que l'on fait
dans le gîte issam al oui peut-on
afficher les pourcentages dans une
colonne c'est paru la même colonne que
les effectifs alors ça peut être
théoriquement possible ce qui est un peu
où c'est un peu compliqué c'est que dans
ces cas là vous allez faire un premier
tableau avec votre pourcentage vous
allez faire un deuxième tableau avec vos
effectifs
vous allez fusionner nos deux tableaux
ensemble donc il ya des choses qui sont
possibles faut jongler il faut tester
jti se marient permet beaucoup de
personnalisation après ce que je vais
vous dire cette fois vous enlevez a
vraiment besoin est passé du temps à
explorer par vous même comment le faire
mais il n'y a pas de solution toute
simple parce qu'en fait l'encré
plusieurs colonnes pour une même
variable - pour la même niveau de la
variable pagne alors il ya une question
est ce que c'est possible de faire le
plan d'échantillonnage en 10 ans là bas
ce sont des gens m alors vous vêtir et
des échantillons enlevés encore une fois
j'ai pas vous faire une réponse toute
prête dépend du type d'échantillonnage
que vous voulez mais vous avez toutes
les fonctions r à des fonctions
d'échantillonnage avec les fonctions
simples avec des probabilités de
recrutement là je vous invite à aller
chercher un peu plus sûr parce qu'il y
aura en soi un cours entier de deux
sondages et je vais prendre la fonction
de cédric valentak qu'en est il des
modèles logistique a été donné pour des
ré depuis ce que ça va me permettre
d'enchaîner
du coup sûr la suite donc là ce que nous
avons vu un c comment la statistiques
descriptives
vous avez toute une série de fonctions
qui sont spécifiques du coup au package
ce revers pour la statistiques
descriptives notamment avec bas donc
d'abord les villes qui se créèrent les
tests vous avez aussi une fonction usb
ici ses propres pour les intervalles de
confiance d'une proportion donc ces
fonctions là vous sont vous sont
clairement indiqué son analyseur sache
et finalement dans la plupart des cas on
peut s'en sortir avec t-bills marie
ndiaye sommes amis et on est bien
tibi lsv lycée mamie c'est la même chose
que tu y vit en somalie mais adapté au
plan d'échantillonnage complexe quand il
sait
de réaliser une régression logistique
binaire vous vous souvenez nous avions
vu la fonction glm qui permet de
réaliser les modèles linéaires
généralisée et vous avez en fait
directement une fonction svg m
alors je n'ai pas la réaliser ici parce
qu'ils feraient que je prenne du temps
pour faire du rpt codage mais si on
retourne sur le site analyseur et que
l'on va sur le cours dédiés à la
régression logistique binaire vous avez
toute une section consacrée à se lever
ou pour vous présenter les choses
la régression logistique finnair se se
fait avec la fonction svn dévoyé ça se
fait exactement de la même manière que
la régression logistique ont aimé lui
on indique notre modèle sport orties de
sexe plus sage plus collige plus leur tv
sauf que le passé un jeu de données
on y passe à un plan d'échantillonnage
ans donc c'est un objet esb design ce
qui va changer
alors petite chose ici ça fonctionne
bien parce que tous leurs conages on a
vu un sous la médiation jessica beaucoup
de réglages à faire en amont a été fait
avant et ensuite on a déclaré notre vie
lui design ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure
donc fait voir que d'âge avec les
fonctions classiques puis transformer
votre jauge de données en objet design
et vous appelez ce végétal
il ya une petite subtilité néanmoins
c'est que si vous faites family galles
binomiale que la régression logistique
binaire vous allez avoir un problème
et si vous regardez le message d'israël
vous dites integer 6 et 6 dans un beau
diable binomiale vous avez un nombre
entier le succès à monde entier des
chèques entier de personnes qui font du
sport est un outil de personnes qui ne
font pas du sport ce qui permet
d'appliquer la loi binomiale qui du mois
discrète
or là du fait de nos poids et bien il ya
des joints qui représente 2 25 individus
qui représente 8 12 et donc du coup on
se retrouve avec un nombre de succès qui
n'est pas entier et un nombre d'échecs
n'est pas entier est en fait il suffit
simplement de lieu d'avoir recours à la
fonction binomiale d'avoir recours à la
fonction poésie binomiale la fonction
poisy binomiale est quasiment
équivalente à la fonction binomiale en
fait c'est une sorte d'extension
continue de la loi binomiale donc en
fait c'est une loi binomiale qui quand
on a des choses ordinaires de même chose
sauf que on peut avoir à 22.5 individus
qui ont réussi donc la subtilité quand
on est avec pour
logistique binaire c'est de remplacer
binomiale par coisy binomiale le
résultat des courses vous n'avez donc là
vous avez vous obtenez un objet de
régression qui a pris en compte le plan
d'échantillonnage lanka de plus il est
dans les poids et en fait quasiment
toutes les autres fonctions qu on a vu
fonctionne donc vous pouvez appliquer
tibet libre échange sans aucun problème
aux résultats de svm vous pouvez
appliquer ggf modèle sans problème sur
les résultats de svg est là et si ce
n'était pas le cas y encore quelques
années servait fournit maintenant une
méthode aller csbj mêmes qui permet
d'estimer va hisser sur un modèle
calculé avec bgl m
et donc du coup comme on a une version
prenant compte le plan d'échantillonnage
complexe pour estimer la hisser on peut
appliquer ce texte là seul petit souci
c'est l'extension effect qui n'étaient
pas compatibles avec mgm donc on a vu un
fx qui nous permet de regarder les
distributions marginal
alors ça serait vérifiée le problème
c'est que parfois quand je fais des
courses ça a changé dans les six
derniers mots dont les douze derniers
mois vous faudrait vérifier je crois
qu'aujourd'hui fx n'est pas n'est
toujours pas compatible avec svg rêve
mais c'est probablement amenée à évoluer
à évoluer à l'avenir je vais pas
vraiment aborder la de suite la
régression multi-nominé ordinale parce
qu'on les a pas encore vu ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que parfois pour certains
types de modèles c'est un peu plus
compliqué il ya des solutions qui
existent et on les verra quand on aura
l'occasion de faire une session je pense
dans quelques semaines une fois qu'on
aura on aurait abordé la plupart des
statistiques de base ont ré abordera du
coup le cas particulier des différents
types de modèles vous d'être le poisson
logistique mythique de mian logistique
ordinale et ainsi de suite
et en fait suivant les cas de figure on
va avoir des solutions pour arriver à
prendre en compte les plan
d'échantillonnage complexe quand il ya
besoin
dans d'autres cas de figure comme la
semaine prochaine on va aborder
l'analyse factorielle on n'a pas
vraiment de version corrigée la nes
factorielle alors il ya des débats dans
les experts et je ne pourrais pas vous
dire si faut-il ou nous prendre en
compte la pondération dans l'analyse
factorielle donc sachez que dans
certains cas il ya des débats dans les
disciplines l'enverra que quand il n'y a
pas de doute y spécifiquement servait
dans ce cas là on va se contenter de
de prendre en compte simplement une
pondération encore une fois sa dépense
et les techniques ont des besoins
particuliers de calcul de variance il
nous reste un dernier point à voir avant
malgré tout de finaliser la session
d'aujourd'hui c'est la question des
graphiques
alors on va essayer de faire un
graphique simple avec gégé pelote
d'accord je vais commencer je suis pas
se faire un graphique en barres on va
faire déjà graphique ainsi comme comme
si les pas de pondération en parle pas
d'élément donc je vais faire un
graphique empare de la probabilité de
faire du sport en fonction du sexe donc
gg pelote
hdv 2003 +1 es en x je vais donc mettre
sexe fils égale sport plus gmbh a donc
là j'ai un graphique qui nous présente
les gens qui font du sport là c'est les
effectifs et la scène graphique commune
obtient classiquement sans prendre en
compte la pondération sur ce type de
graphique là je ne représente pas un
intervalle de confiance sur ce type de
graphique là je n'ai pas les poids sont
largement suffisants il ya pas mal de
corrections particulière à faire on l'a
vu tout à l'heure quand vingt tableaux
croisés
le fait qu'on soit en grappe ou
stratifier ne change pas grand chose il
suffit d'avoir les poids là où ça pose
problème et où le plan d'échantillonnage
un impact différencier c'est lorsque
l'on représente quelques unes des
valeurs la centrafique là peu importe la
méthode kraft ratifié ça ne change pas
la seule chose que j'ai besoin de
prendre en compte sont des points et
pour ça on peut rajouter à l'esthétique
qui s'appelle ruiz
donc on peut ajouter une valeur de
poivre même si je rajoute witt égale
pourquoi les poissons pris en compte par
la ce qui se passe c'est que c est quand
donc comme tout à l'heure ça c'est comme
sur notre tableau croisé classique c'est
pas réajusté sur une taille
d'échantillon donc c'est bien les
données la somme des poires pas
forcément ce qui est le plus intéressant
donc je vais représenter dans le cas
présent j'aurais plutôt imposition et
d'un fils j'aimerais être là quand et
arrêté marais ça peut arriver donc là
que j'ai eu un petit accident
il viendra démarré je ne suis plus dans
mon projet donc généreux choisir mon
projet moblin r10 il est en train de
mourir et non ce que je vais faire je
vais régler q tu es tout
voitures des biens charger mémoire pour
les éléments dont j'ai besoin ça peut
arriver
alors je vous montre le graphique
donc là je fais j'ai mis en position
d'un fils pour avoir plutôt des
pourcentages on joue bien peu congé des
poids comme ça qu'ils ont tant c'est
plus simple appareil pourcentage qu'on
le présente un public de que de plus de
poids qui ne correspondent pas des
choses que les que les gens à qui je
vais en parler vont se représenter
rapidement on va améliorer les gens vont
les choses on va rajouter donc pour ça
degée galli les étiquettes des
pourcentages
pour rappel pour ça il nous faut la
statistique propre et il faut qu'on
indique avec bague comment est-ce qu'on
calcule nous pourcentage ont clairement
est calculé pour chaque sexe je vais
ajouter
j'ai un texte
[Musique]
j'aime texte et d'où je sais un statut
égal propre position position fils
pointe 5% très long mais rectangle si je
fais ça gèle pourcentage
vous voyez j'ai juste besoin de rajouter
ou weight âgé pelote du coup ce type de
représentation graphique 1 pour faire
des graphiques là je suis parti de mon
d'objets data ferai pas mon objet design
simplement je tiens compte de la
pondération dont quelques unes des
points et du coup je vais pouvoir me
sentir ce qui est plus compliqué ça
serait des graphiques du type une droite
de régression linéaire dans un dans un
usage en point parce que là il va y
avoir une marge d'incertitude autour de
ma droite de régression linéaire et donc
là je ne serais pas directement correct
ou si je faisais des graphiques qui
représentait des intervalles de
confiance donc retenez que dans ces cas
là un temps que mon graphique ne pose
pas de problème est que les pondérations
me suffisent
je peux directement utiliser la
paramètres weitz danger plane 2 dès lors
que gêné graphique plus complexes où il
faudra prendre en compte correctement
des intervalles de confiance
je ne peux pas juste utilisé ggp lot 2
j'aurais peut-être besoin de faire en
amour le calcul des différents
indicateurs avec les fonctions servait
et transpirer en fait huit différents
graphiques à partir d'un tableau de
résultats pré calculées alors il ya une
petite astuce quand on objet de type
surveiller design comme on dws que je
peux faire un graphique directement avec
alors il ya une astuce et vous l'avez
danger galli c'est la fonction
ggf pays commence à peine à parler vous
je vais retrouver c'est la fonction ah
non avant c'est d'entourer chez nerfs
qu'elle se trouve
cgg servait et gégé servait dans le
questionnaire donc beaucoup de cheveux
verts vous avez une fonction gg servait
d'accord et la fonction jugé servait en
fait
eh bien on me passe un jeu donné ici
donc ça serait db est en fait elle vient
remplacer le tout début du jeu bloods et
tout le reste c'est identique sauf qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'indiquer aux ouailles
illégal points donc gg ses revers avec
les limites qui sont encore une fois à
condition qui a pas d'implications
calcul de variantes parce que en fait la
seule chose que fait j'ai sauvé c'est
une fonction pour se faciliter la vie
ça va ça prend votre objet serait design
sans un extrait les variables ça
récupère les poids et sa appel ggp lot
en m'appelant automatiquement les poils
enquête à la variable waits ce qui fait
je n'ai pas besoin de redéfinir les
points derrière mais et donc je vous
montre l'aide d'un de gégé servait gg
servait c'est vraiment juste une
fonction qui permet
c'est une fonction qui facilite enfin le
graphique gpu
lorsque ce qu'on a au départ c'est pas
un objet tata poèmes mais directement un
objet design
en tout cas les deux choses qu'on a fait
ici elles sont parfaitement équivalente
en inde même graphique à la fin et
encore une fois les graphiques sont
correctes a selon gas and lies tant que
seulement les pois ou un impact sur le
calcul de graphiques voient la cc c'est
juste une fonction qui facilite un petit
peu les choses
notamment lorsqu'on a des ponts des
chantages que complet qui est du coup ce
qu'on a fourni à servait s'est pas
directement des poids mais en fait des
variables de correction qui pourrait
extraire les points avec nice pour
préparer alors pour rêver un tout petit
peu plus loin
sachez que mon petit arrière ne
fonctionne pas avec les bacs et soeurs
mais il existe à une extension qui vise
à permettre
[Musique]
d'utiliser les herbes dites playa son
service et serviraient caire pour ma
part j'ai jamais vraiment utiliser où
j'en serai un peu prudent mais si ça
vous intéresse cran srv hier alors le
package tresserre levé hier le paquet
est présenté ici
et les vues abonnés de dix plats hier
sur le package servait et donc pour
viser 1 minute et 1 sunrise ou ce genre
de choses je crois pas qu'il ya des
petites subtilités sur ce paquet ils
sont pour ma part je n'ai pas testé il
m'a vraiment utilisé je reste vraiment
sur cette approche qui ait jamais donné
avec un data femme je fais toutes mes
recodification et je transforme en un
objet servait au moment l'analyse qu'on
ait besoin parce que je trouve des
objets slovènes ne sont pas du tout
adaptés et pratique pouvoir parce que je
les trouve pas pratique pour la
manipulation de données
donc c'est ce que je vous recommande
mais si certains veulent aller plus loin
avait exploré bah voilà la formation et
dames je pourrais pas vous donner de
conseils dessus alors je vous propose
qu'on s'arrête là pour ce soir
juste quelques quelques derniers
conseils à propos des mots des modèles
déjà vous voyez les bleus
quand vous avez des choses où ce sont
des poids denquête je ne parle pas de
poids qui sont qui indique simplement
que telling correspond à deux ou trois
observations real et qu'on a vraiment
des poils enquête
passé par servais regardez bien la
documentation votre enquête pour voir si
elle est ratifiée bon grappe est
indiquée du coup les strates et les
grappes ça peut changer de manière
importante de vos résultats et c'est
vraiment essentiel du point de vue mais
dodo même si vous n'avez pas de strates
ou de grappes indiqué passer par servais
malgré tout si ces dépouilles dans
lequel ça devrait pour calculer les
poids de calage sur marge des poids qui
prennent en compte dès qu'ils sont
ajustés sur une corrigeant fait des
problèmes d'intrusion illégale parce que
vous l'avez vu ça change les résultats
des calculs dès lors n'est sur les
thèses de comparaison les valeurs les
intervalles de confiance
c'est relativement facile quand vous
êtes avec les statistiques descriptives
[Musique]
pour les statistiques descriptives rate
n'est qu'on a maintenant qu i b e s vise
svc mari est disponible pour les modèles
classiques on à esbly glm pour les
graphiques on s'en sort assez facilement
dès lors qu'ils ajustent les pois
prendre en compte quand on doit prendre
en compte des imprécisions d'objets de
faire la statistique en amont de faire
des graphiques et de manière globale de
plus en plus de pâques et j'arrive à
tenir compte de ce revers ceci étant dit
il peut y avoir d'autres approches
je pense notamment ceux qui sont
d'épidémiologie par exemple qui ont des
essais en de miser en cluster
on aura rarement recours à servette
parce que c'est pas le genre du ticket
mois moody's ont des idéologies c'est
plus une petite et grande enquête et
dans ces cas-là on veut pouvoir prendre
en compte des effets cluster avec des
modèles mist des modèles ge
on abordera un ce type de modèle aussi
plus complexe dans quelques semaines si
tout va bien ici on peut continuer voilà
mes donc il n'ya pas de encore une fois
ce que je vous présente deux vous
dispense jamais d'avoir une lecture dans
votre domaine thématique dans votre
domaine disciplinaire sur les usages sur
ce qui se pratique en termes de petits
statistiques pour savoir qu'est ce qui
est le plus adapté pour conclure du coup
sûr les données pondérées fait toujours
codage et aux manipulations en amont sur
un data from classique en utilisant des
plats y avait tous les autres outils à
notre disposition et qu'on a déjà vu ça
c'est le premier point
deuxièmement une fois les codages
effectués c'est là que vous déclarez le
design effets du coup vos analyses
en tenant compte de la pondération
d'ailleurs simple la même logique avec
les données labellisés pour ceux qui
importent des données depuis 16 s p cs
usta taille qui sont koné sous la forme
valeur numérique avec des étiquettes de
valeur avec la belle d' c'est pareil
vous pouvez conserver le format la belle
trentenaire manipulation de données et
au moment de l'analyse il faut convertir
en facteur ou en variable numérique
classique c'est pareil fait de
manipulations d'amour et aux romans
l'analyse vous votre ans hormis tous
voila
[Musique]
dans tous les cas on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine la semaine prochaine
nous allons commencer à aborder
l'analyse factorielle des
correspondances pour enchaîner la
semaine suivante sur la table avant la
semaine prochaine sur l'analyse des
correspondances multiples qui est une
des formes de dellys factorielle pour
enchaîner la scène suivante sur la
classification hiérarchique et puis on
va du coup petit à petit commencé à
aborder des techniques de banques est un
peu plus complexe pour aborder aussi
prochainement l'analyse de survie merci
à vous très bonne soirée et du coup on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine à très
bientôt